[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday October 20th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
after back-to-back quarters of
subscriber losses Netflix appears to be
turning things around on Tuesday it said
it added 2.4 million subscribers more
than double what it had forecast
as Netflix battles growing competition
and streaming a space it once easily
dominated
it's been testing out new ways to
increase visits to its site boost
revenue and of course get new members to
sign up joining us to discuss all of
that and where Netflix goes next is our
Netflix and streaming reporter Sarah
Krauss hi Sarah thanks for joining me
thanks for having me so Sarah Netflix
subscriber growth for the third quarter
was surprising to a lot of people what
do we know about how it pulled off that
boost so Netflix added 2.4 million new
subscribers in the September quarter and
they had said to Wall Street that they
were likely to gain a million customers
Netflix shares were up about 14 as of
Wednesday morning which sort of reflects
the jump that happened in after hours
trading after the earnings report they
were helped During the period by
releases of popular shows like Cobra Kai
they had some high profile movies
released like the gray man which is one
of their films where they're trying to
sort of really do some franchise
building which Netflix hasn't really had
in the past as well as some surprise
wins like purple hearts which is not you
know like the flashiest of movies but
did do very well among its viewers and
then finally towards the end of the
quarter the Jeffrey Dahmer story has
done incredibly well and shot up to the
top of its most watched TV charts so the
combination of that really strong
content sort of lifted them during the
period so Netflix saw the subscriber
growth where did it come from
the vast majority of the subscriber
growth for Netflix during the third
quarter was from Asia they did add
customers in each region but Asia was
really the sort of outstanding region in
terms of net new subscribers another
interesting sort of change during the
quarter was that for the first time in
Netflix's history the number of
subscribers in Europe the Middle East
and Africa surpassed the customer base
in the US and Canada now the U.S and
Canada is still the largest market by
Revenue but it's interesting to see as
Netflix makes that International push
where that growth is coming from and is
that growth also translating to the kind
of content that they have on the
platform it is I mean one of the things
that you've seen squid game was sort of
an early example of it of content that
started in Korea and then really spread
like wildfire and took off around the
world in the third quarter one of the
sort of strengths that the company
called out was extraordinary attorney Wu
which is another Korean title but that
did well globally there was another film
from Denmark that also did really well
and so Netflix definitely played up the
idea that you know hey we're making hits
in other parts of the world that are
appealing to viewers and all different
sorts of markets that having a hit in
one country or region doesn't mean that
that content is going to stay there so
there's been this focus on content but
you know they've also been looking at
other strategies to get subscribers and
to keep subscribers one of them is this
ad supported tier we've mentioned it a
few times on the show where do things
stand with that so Netflix is in the
midst of two really important strategic
shifts that are pretty fundamental to
its fortunes going forward the first is
the ad tier is you say and Netflix the
week prior to its earnings report made
more sort of concrete announcements
around its ad tier so it said that the
plan will roll out in early November and
that it will cost 6.99 a month so having
that Clarity around the pricing and the
expected launch date I think gave
investors a lot of confidence another
thing to note about both the price point
and the timing is that it's a dollar
less per month than what Disney will
charge for its ad tier starting in
December and the launch is a month
before Disney so maybe trying to
undercut some of the competition what's
the other way that they're looking to
boost Revenue the other important
strategic shift is cracking down on
password sharing so one of the things
that helped Netflix as it grew was that
members sort of widely shared their
accounts and Netflix kind of celebrated
it for a while too because it was
visibility for the platform people
talked about what they were watching
with friends and family they share their
password but now we're in a whole
different sort of streaming landscape
where competition is such that Netflix
needs to make sure that it's maximizing
the money it makes from each customer
and so they've said that early next year
they're going to ask households that
share accounts outside of the bounds of
what their plans allow to pay a little
bit more to do so what is Netflix doing
to keep track of subscriber movement
whether they're dropping off the
platform or you know staying but maybe
not using it as much how are they
keeping track of users activity so
Netflix has a number of internal metrics
that help it keep an eye on the quality
of content and the success of the
content Investments that they're making
as well as the product improvements and
viewers overall engagement with the
platform so a really important metric
for Netflix lately in particular is not
only how sticky content is so what
percent of people who start watching a
title make it through 75 minutes or more
in the first month basically but also
the number of times per month that
members are coming back to the platform
and that's something that really matters
as Netflix is trying to keep members
engaged at a time when streaming
consumers generally have become more
fickle and are more willing to turn off
Services when they're not active using
it at the same time Netflix is trying to
understand how people are streaming now
that they're going back to the office
and traveling more and doing more
activities outside of the home you know
Sarah it feels like even though we're
talking about Revenue even though we're
talking about subscribers we keep coming
back to content and you know analysts
we've heard over and over again say
content is King and even with growing
competition in the streaming space if
you have good content your platform will
be fine but we are seeing so much more
competition in this space so does that
still hold true content is the
differentiator still and as you say it's
a hard thing to win on because it takes
a lot of really smart bets and smart
dollars spent and it's the thing that
these platforms now there's about a
dozen mainstream streaming Platforms in
the US they're all competing on the same
thing so you know Netflix said that it
feels like its pipeline is really strong
and that they've gotten better at sort
of smoothing out releases such that they
have a steady March or steady drum beat
of hits that are likely to create Buzz
at that in turn drives fresh sort of
subscribers to Netflix or that keeps its
current subscriber base really excited
all right that's our Netflix and
streaming reporter Sarah Krauss thanks
so much for explaining this for us Sarah
thank you and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you